authors and books every weekend on
cspan2
christopher hayes host of msnbc's up
with chris hayes and editor-at-large of
the nation magazine contends that
americans distrust of once-respected
institutions is due to the failures of
our leaders and their social and
economic distance from the rest of the
population
this is just over an hour
[Music]
how we doing cambridge
well that's a very kind reception thank
you very much
um well that was uh
exceptionally kind uh john's words and
um
i'm really
honored that he would say that and um
it is a strange thing to undertake
writing a work of social
criticism because really who am i
but you know someone has to do it
i thought i'd start
speaking about
the starting point for the book and then
since i'm here in cambridge mass i
thought i'd focus what i talked about
tonight on on meritocracy since that
seems
a kind of belly in the beast sort of
thing here
um
um
the books basically starts with a
feeling
and i think it's a feeling that a lot of
people can relate to it's the feeling
that i had after living through what i
call in the book the failed decade
the seemingly unending cascade of
institutional crisis corruption and
failure that comprised the oughts
and that sensation that feeling
of
disorientation that emanated from this
cascade of failure was something that
stalked me increasingly as i attempted
both to navigate life as an adult
citizen in the first decade in which i
was in the adult world as an adult
citizen
and also to be a reporter attempting to
report on public life and often finding
myself in
the circumstance in which i was asked to
adjudicate a question that i felt i
could not adjudicate
and the reason i could not adjudicate it
is because the traditional sources of
authority that i would look to
seem to be totally bankrupted
i mean
you go to your mechanic
and you basically trust
that he is going to
engage in a good faith effort to
fix your car
but if you're like me who has absolutely
no automotive knowledge to speak of
it's totally possible he rips you off
and increasingly it felt that the pillar
institutions in american life and the
elites who ran them were like
corrupt mechanics
that they were basically using and
abusing their authority
towards terrible ends that resulted in
crisis and yet
it was hard to know what to replace
their
expertise with
i mean
i assume you could teach yourself how to
fix a car but that would be a long
undertaking
and of course as we navigate public life
there's a whole host of issues that we
have to confront just from the
perspective of being an engaged citizen
in which we're forced to rely on the
bedrock of institutional authority
i mean we're having a debate right now
it's playing out in newspapers about the
iranian weapons program
well what
how do you figure out
the iranian nuclear weapons program in
the wake of iraq i mean honestly i sit
there and i read the articles and i
literally don't know what to think
some of them seem persuasive that there
is actually a pretty developed nuclear
program but a lot of things i remember
reading in the run-up to iraq was pretty
persuasive the weapons of mass
destruction
so that feeling of disorientation that
feeling of not knowing who to trust that
feeling of being adrift in a profound
way as if the lines on the map and the
names of the places have been stripped
away
to me was the defining
affective reality
of life in america at the end of the
failed decade
and i came across some data that made me
think that this was actually broadly
shared it was data from the general
social survey which is a longitudinal
survey of american public opinion
about americans trust in their pillar
institutions
and it turns out we've been basically
polling on this since 1973 1973 being
the last time the nation was going
through a wrenching crisis of authority
and a time in which there was a great
deal of social criticism and public
debate about the fact of the crisis of
authority
and so polling organizations including
the general social survey and pew and
gallup started asking people how they
felt about their public institutions
and the irony is that that period of
time
what we would think of as the nadir of
trust in american filler institutions
appears in retrospect to have been a
high water mark
that's in the wake of watergate
the wake of the vietnam war
actually trust in americans trust in
their pillar institutions and by that i
mean
congress the presidency banks
newspapers tv news
science
even organized religion
are at or near all-time lows during this
decade
there is one institution in american
life that has gained confidence it is
the only institution in american life
that has trusted
a great deal by a majority of
respondents that of course is the united
states armed forces
the least trusted institution in
american life is the united states
congress
whose approve approval ratings as we've
we've said on the show before are below
paris hilton
and the u.s going communist
so you have a situation right now in
which the least trusted institution
american life is the
bedrock core foundational institution
that the founders put in article one
the representative legislative body the
most trusted institution is the standing
army that the founders didn't think we
had use for and didn't want us to have
and that strikes me as a somewhat
strange institutional landscape
so then the question becomes why do we
have this lack of trust and i think
there's more or less two theories on
this one and this is something that
you'll see david brooks write about
occasionally that
the problem isn't the institutions the
problem isn't that our elites are
performing poorly the problem is that
people just want too much
that they're whining
that basically we've created a media
environment that so feeds on constant
negativity and distrust that the people
in power can't catch a break
jamie dimon at davos said i just think
this refrain of bankers bankers bankers
is really unproductive
bob bennett who is a senator from utah
who i talked to uh for the book
who was uh unceremoniously
dumped by the republican party of utah
and at state convention for a tea party
insurgent basically said to me look um
you know people read responsible
publications uh and they have trust for
those of us at labor institutions we'll
be fine but if all you're reading are
blogs and such then you just think we're
all corrupt and lying to you
and i think there's something to that i
mean i think there's an intuitive appeal
to that story we we definitely do feel
that the media and the 24-hour news
cycle of which i suppose i am now apart
does have this this this turmeric effect
on our trust it does eat away at a
certain level i mean the best example of
this i think is in another era
we would not have seen anthony weiner's
crotch
and it's it's hard to make the case the
republic is any better off for having
had the privilege
but i think ultimately the occam's razor
solution to this uh the question of why
there's there's less trust
is that the institutions have performed
terribly
the elites helming them have performed
terribly i mean we began the decade with
19 men with box cutters overcoming the
largest and most expensive security
apparatus in the history of human
civilization
followed by a war that was the largest
strategic and moral blunder in recent
memory if not in the nation's history of
foreign policy
a hundred and a thousand hundred
thousand of the low end estimates of
iraqis dead 850 billion dollars burned
like oil fires in the desert 4 500
americans dead with many many more
wounded
enron collapsed
in on itself bringing down the largest
one of the largest accounting firms at
the time the largest corporate
bankruptcy in history but since kind of
quaintly eclipsed by the wreckage of the
financial crisis
i'm only up to 2002. 2000
or 2003.
um we then watched a major american city
drown live on national television
while we watched helpless a thousand
people dead in that disaster and all
this comes before the 8 trillion housing
bubble and the wealth that evaporated
more or less overnight and plunged the
nation into the worst financial crisis
in 70 years the wreckage of which we are
still sifting through and digging out of
so i think you can make a pretty good
case that it actually has been a
singularly crappy decade
and that institutional elite performance
has actually been quite bad
and i think that's where to look
to understand this crisis of authority
through which the nation
now muddles
so
why have we had so much elite failure
i
want to tell a story in the book about
meritocracy
now meritocracy has an interesting
origin as a word
it's sort of been lost to history
you won't think i'm excessively informal
if i take my jacket off dude
okay
thank you good sir
it's strong advice
i think we're on book tv so that i think
would be yeah
meritocracy is a neologism that is
coined by a man named michael young in
1955 who is a british left
parliamentarian and social critic who
writes a book a work of social tatir
called the rise of the meritocracy
it's a fascinating book that i commend
you all to read it's written essentially
from the it's
it's a historical monograph written from
the perspective of the year 2020 looking
back at the history which from the point
of view he's writing it is the future of
england
as it develops a system that young calls
meritocracy
and meritocracy more or less
is a kind of repudiation of a basic
democratic impulse
today the author of the monograph tells
us we frankly recognize that democracy
can be no more than an aspiration
and have rule not so much by the people
as by the cleverest people
not an aristocracy of birth not a
plutocracy of wealth but a true
meritocracy of talent
michael young describes these two ways
in which intelligence testing in schools
and productivity testing in firms allows
both of those institutions to sort
through and find the most productive the
smartest the best and brightest to
invoke a phrase
and basically has them rule the society
now this is presented by young as a
dystopic vision
it's a work of social satire and yet
we've adopted the term as a model
in fact young writes this op-ed for the
guardian more or less near the end of
his life saying
how baffled he is
i mean it would be like us like you know
politicians advocating for a brave new
world
or 1984.
because young foresaw quite aptly some
of the downsides of creating such a
system but it remains the case that in
america today
the adjective meritocratic
is always and everywhere
a compliment
the adjective bureaucratic is always and
everywhere an insult
no one gets home for their first day at
their new job and saying i love this
place it is totally
bureaucratic we all understand
what that word means but you might get
home and say it's a great place it's
completely meritocratic
meritocracy is the name that we've
adopted and we've given to
what is essentially
both a social model that we more or less
all buy into across a political and
ideological spectrum
as well as a set of institutions
some of which are in this town
that are part of producing
that model
and in some senses
it's um
it's a modern version of a very old idea
i mean de tocqueville writes about the
fact that you know there's no peasants
in america they don't even have the word
because they don't have the
inheritance of feudalism though of
course there's slavery
and
this idea that in america you could rise
from any station in life as far as your
talents and drive would take you is what
we basically call the american dream
it's a dream of social mobility it's a
dream of a kind of sorting process in
which the contingent features about your
background or your
pedigree are less important than what
you can do
and as such it's a remarkably appealing
one
the meritocracy is a specific
incarnation of that american dream in
which we basically say we are not going
to bar entrance to the american elite
based on these contingent features
like race and gender and pedigree and
geography and sexual orientation rather
people of all different creeds and
colors will complete on the
level playing field the metaphor we
always use
side note level playing field a phrase
invented in the 1970s by a bank lobbyist
trying to undo bank regulation
hilarious
that we're all going to compete on the
level playing field and then this
sorting process is going to sort down to
find the people who are the smartest and
most industrious
and they will make the big decisions
they'll get the big paychecks on wall
street
and
there is something remarkably appealing
about this model i mean
the fact that barack obama is president
is exactly the meritocracy's crowning
glory it is only under that social model
that that man with that name and that
skin color and that background could be
present in the united states and it is a
testament to the system
that he was able to become president
united states
that he was able to come to harvard law
and be formed in the networks of harvard
law and go on
to become president united states
but during the same period of time in
which we've adopted the social model
we have seen
radically accelerating inequality
and more importantly and less covered
declining social mobility
now social mobility proves to be
incredibly tricky to measure and there's
a lot of debate about what you actually
are even measuring and whether you're
measuring mobility over the course of a
lifetime or intergenerationally but if
you look at the data in total if you
look at the literature what you see is
the strong suggestion
that it is getting harder to start at
the bottom and work your way to the top
that the odds of starting at the bottom
and working your way at the top grow
longer over time that it was easier to
do that 20 and 30 and 40 years ago than
it is to do it now which is to say that
the meritocracy is failing to deliver on
its central and foundational promise
it isn't giving us the thing that it is
supposed to give us
and why is that
so in the book i talk about my own high
school and i should be take a moment to
say that um
it's always funny to watch people rail
against the elites
when you think they're one you're
they're one of them
i mean i went to heritage foundation and
saw dick armey
he was wearing a 10 gallon hat and
cowboy boots
um
rail against the elites
and i was like
bro
who are we who are we kidding here
i know where you work
so i want to make sure that i'm not
doing the same which is to say i'm
implicated in the story of this book and
i'm implicated as someone who has been
formed by the same institutions that i'm
critiquing and one of those institutions
is a place that i have profound profound
affection for which is my high school
it's a place by the name of hunter
college high school in new york city
it's a public school public magnet
school draws from all five boroughs and
in the way that it operates it embodies
the most
noble and austere vision of meritocracy
kids line up on a cold winter day in
january 11 year olds 6th graders who
have scored sufficiently high on their
state regents tests
and
they line up and they take a test
and about three to four thousand kids
take that test and about 185 get in
and if you score high enough you get in
if you don't you don't
just one test
there's no other metrics there's no
essay no interview certainly no legacy
admissions
if the mayor's daughter doesn't make
a high enough score she's not getting in
and there's precious few institutions in
american life about which that could
credibly be said
right
and so in that sense it seems
relatively uncorruptable
and what's happened in hunter college
high school is that over time
the percentage of black and latino
students gaining entries in school has
dwindled dramatically to the point where
it is now three and one percent
now black and latino students have
always been vastly underrepresented at
hunter high school this is partly due to
a massive story about testing inequities
educational inequity the color of
poverty in new york city etc
but it's gotten worse over the last 10
or 15 years and part of the reason it's
gotten worse well there's two reasons
one is those kids showing up on that
cold january day as i did obviously
aren't all coming with the same
endowments in terms of what their
primary education is look like
they're coming from very different
places with different very different
endowments of social capital
literacy
of education
and then on top of that
there is now a test prep industry for
the hunter test
which is of course inevitable because a
good education new york city is a scarce
resource and that scarce resource can be
priced on the market and the dollars
flow into new york city from the capital
of finance and those dollars have to
find somewhere to rest
and so there is now a test prep industry
in new york where you can pay 90 an hour
in the wealthier precincts of manhattan
for a tutor for your child in sixth
grade you can pay a thousand dollars for
what's called a cram school where your
kid goes during winter break for a week
every day to work on the test
and there's no records kept on this but
the reporting that i've done at the
school suggests that now a majority of
students getting in have gone through
some test prep
regime
and the story
about what's happened to hunter and this
test prep regime
to me is a really important parable for
thinking about how meritocracies break
down
we want to say there is a neat division
between equality of opportunity and a
quality of outcome
that's the foundational premise
of our meritocratic vision
everyone's going to line up at the
starting line and everyone's going to
jump when they hear the gun and then
people will come in with different times
but of course it is the case that in
reality vast inequality of outcomes
subvert the mechanisms by which we might
provide a quality of opportunity even in
not straightforwardly corrupt ways like
a donor giving a wing to a university so
that their kid gets in
even in the way that the test prep
industry has queered this institution in
new york which does hew with admirable
clarity to this basic meritocratic
vision
and i write in the book about what i
call the iron law of meritocracy which
is borrowing a phrase from a social
theorist who i think is a really
important one who wrote this remarkable
book which doesn't get talked about a
lot but i also would recommend you to
read this called political parties and
it's a social theorist named robert
michelle's
michelle's was a a student of webers and
he was a german
a leftist an anarcho-syndicalist
he didn't like the the bougie softness
of the social democrats so he went for
the more radical parties and then he
went to those radical parties and he
found that the radical parties had the
same problem that social democrats had
which all parties on the left seem to
share which is the starting point for
the book he wrote which is basically
this
why is it the case
that parties of the left committed to an
egalitarian and democratic vision
always end up devolving into a small
clique of people making all the
decisions
i can understand he says why this
happens on the right because frankly
that's the ideological disposition of
the right they believe in hierarchy they
believe in concentration of power but
why does it happen on the left and he
develops over the course of the book
this thing he calls the iron law of
oligarchy
which is a sort of depressing iron law
in which he says basically
organization and the division of labor
and tasks creates oligarchy inevitably
who says organization says oligarchy
someone's going to run the party press
someone's going to take the notes at the
meeting someone's going to open up the
union hall
and those folks find ways to use the
power
that they are imbued with as an
organizational necessity to subvert the
means by which democratic accountability
might be applied to the party in the
organization
now michelle's then
took a dark turn
and decided the only way to truly
represent the working class was through
a charismatic leader and became a
fascist
so i
don't believe in that part
the iron law of meritocracy which i
write about in the book is essentially a
corollary to this which says who says
meritocracy says oligarchy
that the concession that meritocracy
makes to inequality this foundational
belief that there is some small subset
of the best and brightest to whom we
will give
the most power and remuneration
that it is impossible over the long run
to preserve the distinction between
quality of opportunity and quality of
outcome that the inequality that we the
meritocracy teaches us to tolerate and
embrace will ultimately corrupt and
queer and skew and deform
any commitments to the basic equality of
opportunity that lies at the
meritocracy's heart
and i think we've seen this
all over the country
there's a few other things about
meritocracy that i think are problematic
let's see how much time we have
you guys good we're good okay let's keep
going for a little bit
um
i write in the book a chapter about
organizations and institutions that
fashion themselves as meritocracies
and one of those is major league
baseball
and i write about major league baseball
because i like major league baseball i'm
a baseball fan
i'm a cubs fan actually
um
which is which is character building
and ironically i'm i'm i'm a cubs fan
i'm a cubs fan who was born and raised
three miles from yankee stadium
by a father from the north side of
chicago who raised me a cubs fan
so instead of rooting for the most
storied and glory glorious franchise in
all time
i was given the cubs
which i think somehow explains my
politics in some way
yes that's right well you guys
sorry that we took him but i think it's
good for us
um
okay so so
major league baseball really is a
meritocracy right and i think this is
basically true of all major league
sports i mean it you know if you're an
aging slugger who can no longer hit the
fastball it doesn't matter like how
beloved you are or even how big your
contract is sometimes you're going to
end up getting banished or cut
and if you're a 19 year old dominican
kid who can't speak english who no one
has ever heard of
with a high school education or not even
a high school education but you can
throw a 98 mile per hour fastball for
strikes you're gonna see time
and the other feature of major league
baseball that
that meritocracy have is that there's
huge rewards for performance and
punishment for failure
i mean i talked to baseball players and
it was interesting in reporting this
that you know we think about stars and
baseball but most baseball players are
not stars
and most of them live with this horrible
nagging anxiety about being benched or
sent down to the miners
you know you
you've got some condo and some car and
some life and your kid is in school and
maybe you're going to find yourself in
the middle of kansas next week
so there's punishment for failure and
there's huge huge outside rewards for
performance 10 million contracts 50
million contracts if you're good
and the story of the steroid scandal to
me
imparts a very important lesson
which is that it's much harder than it
looks
to design a system with huge rewards for
performance that isn't also a system
with huge rewards for cheating
enron fashioned itself in meritocracy
and in fact the people that i talked to
who worked there said it was an
amazingly meritocratic place there was
this
hostility to bureaucracy of any kind you
could you could basically ignore
directives from your boss cut corners
blow up whole units of the business as
long as it worked and made money
and in fact jeffrey skilling would go
around telling a story about telling his
subordinate not to start an internet
trading business and she went ahead and
did it anyway that made a huge amount of
money
so there was no
seniority no wait your turnism
but of course we saw what happened with
enron
which is that the huge rewards for
performance and these cascaded down to
the organization where basically
everyone had their their compensation
tied up in enron stock and sharon
watkins the whistleblower enron told me
that people would watch the stock during
the day
because it was what they were gonna buy
their house with or send their kids to
college with
huge rewards for performance but also
huge rewards for cheating we saw this on
wall street right
during the rise of the housing bubble
and the securitization machine that
almost blew up the entire world
there was
a kind of confusion between what was
actually performance and what was
cheating
and i think this lesson is particularly
important at this moment in our public
policy debates because we are in the
midst of a national experiment in which
we are converting the model of teachers
and education from a bureaucratic one to
a meritocratic one
we are saying right no more seniority
right that's the problem
accountability punishment for failure
rewards for success
in merit pay
enron had this bizarre well not bizarre
they had this management technique
called rank and yank in which they fired
the bottom 10
of the workforce every other year
we're adopting this meritocratic model
and we should not be surprised when we
adopt it that we get a lot of cheating
and lo and behold we're seeing it
in washington dc there's a massive
scandal happening in atlanta right now
and one of the things that happens in um
in institutions
that have this kind of incentive or
cheating
is that the only thing that stops
cheating if you don't have a specific
set of really enforced rules as baseball
did not it didn't have a testing regime
the thing that that prevents
that draws the line between cheating and
performance are norms
norms are incredibly important i'm
thinking about this more and more as i
watch our political
institutions sink into
dysfunction as we await the affordable
care act decision
the most powerful prohibition is the
prohibition that something quote just
isn't done
and when people start doing the thing
that just isn't done
then those norms go very quickly
and the contagion spreads throughout an
institution particularly an institution
set up along these meritocratic lines
with high rewards performance and harsh
punishments or failure it spreads to the
institution very quickly
and and what you get
in the culture of those institutions and
this is something that um
i talked a lot about when when i was
at the safra center here in harvard
is you get a culture of the open secret
and the inside joke
because people know they're doing wrong
but they need to justify it to
themselves
so there's this amazing tape right enron
was bilking the
taxpayers of california for millions of
dollars by basically shutting down power
plants to jack up prices during the
and there's this tape where someone says
he just
expletives california he just expletives
them
and the supervisor says can you rephrase
that
he says he arbitrages california energy
markets the tune of a million dollars a
day
it was a joke they knew what they were
doing fabrice toure who was the goldman
trader
who put together these
uh securities that were kind of designed
like an ied to blow up
and they sold them to their clients and
then bet against them
and febreze toure writes to his his
several girlfriends actually in these
emails but one of them he writes he
writes to one of these girlfriends
and he says
uh
just just manage to sell some uh see
some of these securities to widows and
orphans in the airport in
belgium right he knows what he's doing
jose canseco in his surprisingly
readable and fascinating memoir juiced
which i quote quite a bit in the book
much to my surprise
um
he talks about baseball players talking
about going to get their b12 shot when
they're gonna go shoot up steroids
and
so you see the ways in which
this um
corner cutting this erosion of norms can
take place and i think you can zoom out
and look at not just the institutional
setting but the ways in which certain
pathologies are produced in our elites
through the process of elite formation
by the process of meritocratic
competition
c.s lewis gave this amazing talk in 1945
at king's college where he said
he said have you ever had the experience
of walking into a room
and two people are talking and as soon
as you walk in the room they stop
talking
he says if you've ever had that
experience then you have experienced
the power and the seduction of the inner
ring
and he says much of the things that you
will do in your life that you will come
to regret stem from desire to be on that
side of the inner ring
that the desire to be on the inside of
the inner ring is the seed bed into
which the seeds of corruption fall
and what we have in our process of elite
formation in the u.s is just an endless
series of inner rings
that is what the meritocracy is quite
explicitly
is the process of moving from the
outside to the inside but never finding
some actual final resting place inside
the nature of the income distribution in
america what i call in the book fractal
inequality means that there's always
some other rung on the ladder to ascend
it's like an m.c escher
painting right it just keeps kind of
going up somehow infinitely defying
logic and if you are always spending
your time with your name your neck
craned upwards thinking about the next
rung on the ladder it diffuses the part
of you that will look downward
to think about what people on the bottom
of the ladder how they're doing
so that's one of the pathologies that is
inculcated i think by this sort of
process of meritocratic formation
i also think that absolute payouts at
the top matter a lot
i think everyone has a price and if the
price is big enough and the payouts are
big enough the odds of that price
finding you are more likely
maybe you won't compromise your
integrity for ten thousand dollars or
even a hundred thousand dollars but when
someone starts saying you can make 10
million dollars you start to kind of
think to yourself all the good you could
do with that 10 million dollars
and those kind of payouts are of course
reality in the current system of
inequality that we've produced
the way in which this manifests itself
in our society i think
is that we have this increasing social
distance
between
the elites and the not only the people
who make decisions and the people who
are on the receiving end of the effects
of those decisions
and hierarchies of all kinds produce
social distance and that social distance
when it grows too great can prove to be
tremendously problematic for them
the core of the book the moral core of
the book
is an argument about inequality that i
think is a little different than the
argument we usually have an inequality
particularly on the left which is an
argument about how inequality makes is
worse for those on the bottom of the
social hierarchy right wage stagnation
outsourcing de-industrialization the
destruction of the social safety net etc
the argument i'm trying to make in the
book
is that one of the most pernicious
effects of inequality is that it makes
those at the top worse
that the more elitist american society
gets the worse the caliber of elites it
produces
and that insight comes from this quote
which to me is
the moral core of the book and is i
think a profound observation about
any kind of hierarchy
which comes from desmond tutu in his
memoir no future without forgiveness
even the supporters of apartheid were
victims of the vicious system which they
implemented and which they supported so
enthusiastically
in the process of dehumanizing another
in inflicting untold harm and suffering
inexorably the perpetrator was being
dehumanized as well
we have a system
of course it is not the moral equivalent
of apartheid i should be quite clear
but we have a system
that cultivates a bunch of really nasty
and pernicious pathologies in the elites
that it produces
and the system of inequality
dooms them in certain ways to
dysfunction
it
creates this self-justifying impulse you
see it on display all the time and i'll
speak for myself right now
you know
successfully marching through
meritocratic institutions requires at
the end of that process although it's a
sort of always ongoing process requires
those who have ascended through it to
write for themselves a story about
overcoming
about moving from the outside to the
inside i think of myself as a
working-class gift from the bronx and my
dad was a community organizer and my mom
was an educator and
you know gosh darn it i worked my way up
and now i have a tv show
the american dream
the cable news host
but the fact the matter is i'm a
straight white man in a society that
gives a lot of breaks to straight white
men i had two incredible parents college
educated parents who
provided an almost impossibly supportive
environment to nurture me and
encouraged me along
i had a lot of privilege but of course
that privilege gets written out of the
story in the biography that you write
for yourself about your meritocratic
achievement and this is true
even in manifestly preposterous
scenarios like mitt romney
i mean mitt romney got up at a
republican presidential primary debate
and he said
i could have inherited the car company
but i didn't do it
i walked away
struck out on my own
came here to cambridge
went to harvard law and harvard business
school
and and and started and started bain
capital while i where i earned every
cent that i made
and anne romney gave it gave it gave an
even more incredible interview in which
he recounts the story of living in dingy
student housing and having to staple
together carpet samples to cover the
floor because they couldn't afford
carpeting and when times got really
rough having to sell mitts inherited
american motor company stock to make
ends meet
and of course this strikes us all as
hilarious as laugh-worthy but i
guarantee you that it is genuinely felt
that is not
said for political purposes i guarantee
you and romney feels like they overcame
right we all feel like we've overcome
and that is really pernicious
that is part of the psychology that
cements the status quo
and this is true of liberals and it's
true of conservatives i think it's i
think liberals are are less aware of the
fact that it's true i think
conservatives embrace this vision much
more transparently
but i think even folks who are formed in
these institutions who end up as
democratic politicians
deep dump deep down somewhere inside
them
they think they've earned it
and that's i think the seedbed of a lot
of corruption
all right with that let's take some
questions
oh you ma'am
hi
thanks
um
you talk a lot about um the education
system what you went through and how and
you just referred about the whole
teacher merit thing yeah um where do you
see that going in education policy
so the question is about where i see
education policy going particularly
along the lines of of merit pay um
you know i think the the advocates of
that system are pretty clearly winning
i think that's just a fact about where
education policy is going
i think the costs and drawbacks of the
kind of model that they are proposing
are undersold and understood
if that makes any sense
and
and that there's going to be
backlash
some inevitable backlash politically and
also i think hopefully in a
healthy policy discussion
when the
downside effects of those become more
manifest so we already saw that with
certain fetish things that have happened
and obviously dianne ravage has written
about this but i mean let's all remember
the gates foundation spent
tens of millions if not hundreds of
millions of dollars because there was
research saying smaller schools produce
better outcomes
and they and i this is true in new york
i mean every school that was like a big
high school now has like nine different
high schools inside it
and
they had this tremendous impact in terms
of reducing
the size of schools
and after doing it it turned out it
didn't really confer any performance
benefits
so there's a certain degree to which um
and this is this is true and we're
seeing this happen at the university of
virginia right you guys familiar with
what happened in the university of
virginia i'm sure this is this crowd yes
um
you know there's a certain degree to
which one of the trends in american life
is that as the public sector draws in
right particularly under this sort of
age of austerity i mean university of
virginia in 1990 got 33.5 percent of its
funding from state revenue now it's nine
percent
right
so i mean so what happens is as the
public sector draws in the space is made
up by
the gates foundation
and
billionaire hedge fund guys
and you know we tried this model of
social provisioning before in the gilded
age
the first
public education system in this state
was funded privately by industrialists
and then at a certain point we decided
that public goods should be provisioned
and those decisions should be made
democratically
and i wonder to the extent to which
there's going to be backlash against
precisely the vector of policy that
you're and you know i feel very
conflicted about this and i won't go
onto this because it's not really my
area of expertise although that's never
stopped a cable news host before
but
but um
you know i
my mom was an educator and she worked in
the system in new york and um i have
people
you know this this topic particularly in
sort of liberal circles can be a little
like israel-palestine like it gets like
very dicey very quickly in terms of
people on on different sides of this
sort of education reform divide
and i think i have some conflicted
feelings but the thing i don't feel
conflicted about is that we are
definitely under counting
and failing to grapple with
the downside risk and costs of the
system that's being proposed
all the way back row
hi uh i'll try to keep this short but uh
you continually refer to merocratic
systems as having high rewards for
success and dire consequences for
failure yeah
but in the book you mentioned a number
of instances and i mean glenn greenwald
does really well in his book about
failure only goes so high up the chain
you can only fall so far once you've
gotten so high and
like was it steve denning at forbes had
that criticism of kind of your
conclusion and saying oh it's just one
piece solution just redistribute wealth
but did you consciously not speak to the
idea of accountability as being part of
at least fixing an existing merocratic
system before replacing it with some
other ideal or was that just an omission
so so the question is about the role
that accountability plays and the fact
that so yeah i want to be clear here the
the the talk about high rewards for
performance and harsh punishment for
failure is an articulation of a certain
theoretical model of what a meritocracy
should be part of the critique laid out
in the book is that our meritocracy has
devolved far away from that in which i
say in the book we have a profound
inequality of accountability in the
country in fact
we have a system that is just
relentlessly punitive on the bottom and
unimaginably forgiving on the top
i mean we put more people in prison
per capita than any industrialized
nation
any industrialized democracy
we're basically neck and neck with china
you know a 16 year old kid in the bronx
who gets stopped and frisked and has
a dime bag of marijuana is going to end
up in the system
and as michelle alexander has written
about in her fabulous book the new jim
crow that sort of marks that kid for
life right
we have a system of employment in this
country in which the vast majority of
workers labor without contracts
which means they're at will employees
which means if you come in
and
you give your boss a dirty look or wear
a tie he doesn't like or call him dude
you can be fired
and yet at the top
it seems like there's no accountability
i mean more baseball players have been
brought before grand juries and juries
because of perjury over steroid use then
major bankers have been brought before
juries for the largest financial crisis
in 70 years
so so clearly yes i mean and so yes i
think accountability is key and
i do write about it some in the book in
terms of the
um
in terms of the
solution section of the book i think
accountability is the first step but i
guess part of the point that i'm making
in in this this the kind of construct of
the iron law of meritocracy is that
that def defusing accountability at the
top is inevitably a consequence of
constructing this kind of system and
that we're deluding ourselves a little
bit if we think we can construct one but
always maintain that accountability at
the top
right that the real source of the lack
of accountability is the
disproportionate power that people at
the top have
substantial public figures like the idea
being isn't that a model that can be
trans used in the transition yeah
absolutely and i think that's really
important and i think there's i think
there's a lot of things about the
proliferation of platforms that have
happened in the internet that do provide
these venues for accountability it
didn't exist before i think that's
groovy
um
is there uh you ma'am there
yes
hi first of all thanks for your book um
as i read it i think one thing that came
to mind was
the concept of reward and it seemed like
the
it was kind of consistent that money was
a reward so it made me think about you
know what
norms and what what values we place on
certain things and what reward should be
so i was wondering if you could talk a
little bit about
whether reward
what reward can
change how it can be changed that's a
great question the question is about
money and reward and the role that plays
and i think there's something really
important here which is that
the particularly in places on wall
street and i spent a lot of time talking
to folks that work on wall street where
there's this very um explicit
meritocratic ethos i mean it's very it's
it's said by people people say it all
the time wall street's meritocracy the
first line of goldman sachs
recruiting page on their website is
goldman sachs as a meritocracy period
um
you know
one of the problems with meritocracy is
that
merit
sounds great to everyone sure yeah give
people with merit more than people
without merit but then it proves to be
much more difficult to define
it's tricky
and so what ends up happening
particularly particularly from wall
street the bonus check
stands in for merit
which of course is a
horrifically self-justifying way of of
defining merit so i think that there's
that
the massive compensation at the top is
part of this kind of vicious cycle
in which reward in terms of monetary
reward and can self-conceptions of merit
kind of reinforce and self and justify
themselves
and i think the other
this is a little tangential the question
about reward but the other the other the
other problem with meritocracy in terms
of this definitional problem right of
merit
is
it also creates what i call in the book
the cult of smartness
and you know i'm as subject to this as
anyone
um
you know this idea that smartness
is this
distinct identifiable ordinal quality
like height
right or like a bonus check you know
someone made 10 million someone made 8
million 74 million or like height where
yao ming is taller than michael jordan
who's taller than danny devito
you know so-and-so in the room is
smarter than such and such it's smarter
than that person there
and you see this all the time you see
these kind of i mean
i'm sure these kind of conversations
happen in this town a lot let me tell
you
right
faculty meetings in law schools
in meetings in the white house among
white house staffers about who should be
listened to in meetings right this idea
that that to shrink down merit to shrink
down the thing that you're defining as
the as the badge whether in money or
smartness as some kind of easily
identifiable
non-problematic quality
in which people are ranked very
obviously is a huge part of the
pathology here
and i think it's precisely in some
senses because merit actually proves to
be so difficult
to define that that in that in
particularly on wall street
you know if you're a lifelong a student
it's nice to have grades
i mean you want that fee i mean i say
this is someone who gets ratings every
tuesday morning
and they completely dictate my mood for
the whole week
as my wife can attest
but there's that desire for grace
there's a desire for something
quantifiable and and and money stands in
for that
okay
next uh you turn the glasses you seem
oh no behind you that's that that
yes ah
two quick things uh one thanks for
bringing the mr rogers dj set thing to
the show because i watched it online and
when you showed it on your show i was
really happy you're welcome and then
second
um with the elite
um presents and stuff like that um do
you think that since
eric holder and obama are
african-american and stuff and the
congressional
republicans are white
and elites that they want to keep them
down
basically
to the 10
bottom do you think that's part of it so
the question is the question is about
the racial subtext of the of the
of the politics of the moan particularly
between the house republican party which
is um the house republican caucus is
not exclusively white but overwhelmingly
white yeah um and and the first black
president and the first black attorney
general um
i think it's impossible to talk about
politics in the obama era without the
subtext of race
um
and
people try to do it and fail because
it's just an inescapable fact it's and
it's more about you know the
the bigger question to me about this i
mean i don't think necessarily they're
for instance like ginning up fast and
furious because they want to bring i
mean let's remember what they did to
jannarino who was the last attorney
general to be held for contempt by a
republican congress but then bring up it
start it with george w bush right sure
but there the point is that the fact
that to the extent they're manufacturing
the controversy um
i think it's just
to think about to think clearly and
rigorously about the role that race is
playing in this it's useful to have
dependent independent variables right so
let's rerun the historical experiment
with bill clinton and there's a whole
lot of behavior that looks remarkably
similar i mean you know scandal
monitoring huge investigations citations
for contempt against janet reno so i
don't necessarily think that that
specific animus is necessarily
racially explained but i also don't
think that that precludes a racial
subtext in it and i think they've been
particularly
loath they've directed a lot of loathing
towards eric holder in a particularly
vicious way that strikes me sometimes
that sort of sets off certain kind of
alarm bells
the way that i think
the way to think i think about
race in the obama era more broadly
is the fact that
increasingly national politics
have the sort of ferocious tribal
quality
that city politics have
and i say this is someone from the bronx
and i love city politics right but like
man the politics between puerto ricans
and the bronx and dominicans in the
bronx
that is ugly
like that's some that's some intense
stuff
and the politics when i was growing up
in new york city between
chabad jews in crown heights and african
americans in that neighborhood you know
that was famously riots right
because in city politics you have
multi-ethnic states essentially
in democratic bottles over resources and
distribution
and as america grows less white
that's the cast that our national
politics take
and it's a fact about our national
politics that we currently have
two coalitions one of which is
essentially exclusively white
and so its prerogatives its interests
what it feels its fighting for cannot
help but be determined and in some sense
is over determined by that brute fact
that there's one coalition that is
essentially a multi-ethnic and
multiracial coalition and if you've ever
been in a campaign office on election
day it is the starkest thing in the
world to see as a reporter to go
to
a call office of a field campaign
for a republican candidate and a call
office for a field campaign for a
democratic candidate it is two americas
one of them is all white
and one of them is not
and so
as much as the specific racial subtext
or racial animus that drives
resentment of barack obama as the first
black president is absolutely present to
me the deeper issue is this structural
fact about the different coalitions in
american politics which are now
largely in these different camps one of
which
has is essentially just a white just
white
all right um
you ma'am there
for i'm enforcing gender equity here so
if i pass you over
hi um so i am sort of part of what
you're describing with the leading into
the meritocracy i'm white i go to a
really excellent college
i have privileged parents
as someone of that generation that's
sort of leading into it and part of a
larger group of that how does one
either avoid it or navigate it
responsibly that's a great question
you know that's a great question so if
if you are a product of the system and
you also have a certain amount of
privilege right the question of how you
navigate it responsibly is the question
and i say this a lot and i'm sure this
this will be broadcast and so i'll get
right-wingers i'll get right-wingers
making fun of this statement but i'll
say it anyway
you know
liberal guilt is gets a bad rap
because the the alternative is just
complacency
now of course if liberal guilt is just
something that you kind of
feel
bad about and then you don't do anything
with it well then it doesn't help anyone
but like people should be guilty about
privileges they have that aren't earned
i mean i feel like i i feel that way
it's part of what drives me
so i think first of all like staying in
touch with that's important and then
also making decisions about what you're
gonna do i mean this sounds preachy and
i don't know you so you should do your
thing
it's a little weird to be giving life
advice to a stranger
um
you know but
making choices to do work that you think
is gonna be meaningful
and is gonna make the world a better
place again that's another sort of pat
liberal phrase but also a really
important one
um
you know 40 of
of princeton grads go work on wall
street something like around between 20
and 30 percent here at harvard
i mean
[Music]
i understand why people do it i'm not i
guess i am judging but
i'm not judging um
but
you know um
there's a lot of work to be done
and i think that folks that have had
privileges um have a duty
a moral duty to do that work
[Music]
all right we're gonna you're gonna get
the last one back there
yes you sir
no sorry actually i'm sorry to do that
to you but i was playing in it my bad
dude
um in case i don't get a chance to be on
your show i wanted to run by you the
three sentences i would use in my less
than a minute at the end and i would
love to get your thoughts on them it's
about the meritocracy of our election
system so the three sentences would be
because our voting machines are
error-prone easy to hack and use with no
citizen oversight we can't know whether
the election results are accurate
not knowing if since we can't know the
election results are accurate the
endless
analysis and interpretation of those
results are rendered delusional that the
media always makes because they're based
on either unverified they're unverified
outcomes they're they're just
speculative outcomes because of this
misstep
we're constantly misled
and
and
misinformed
by the media because
by perpetuating the myth that there's
some good reason to believe unverified
election results and the ever-expanding
speculative narratives that are derived
from that as if they're real so okay so
um
this is a question about the
verifiability and trustworthiness of the
actual
granular details of how we conduct
elections
um i'm i'm unpersuaded largely that
there's any kind of systemic fraud
happening in our election system
um
based on reading about it the way that i
base everything
doing some reporting on it i mean i
could be wrong maybe you're right and
i'm wrong um but
i have looked into it i have done some
reporting on it particularly during i
think the kind of high water mark for
this sort of
discussion which was happening in 2004
yeah yeah let me finish
there is fraud i'm saying that there's
no way sure right so so there's there's
two distinct things right there's the
allegations of fraud and then there's
the fact that the verifiability and the
degraded was traceable it does strike me
that the mechanics by which we count
votes should be verifiable
that currently much of it is not that
verifiable and certainly not audited
but at the same time i think our and
this has to do with polling i mean
generally what happens in elections
as a general rule is that the polling in
the three or four days before the
election looks a lot like what the
result was
it was certainly true in wisconsin it's
generally been the case it was certainly
true in the 2008 election polls were
predicting that barack obama would win
by about the margin he won
it was true in florida yeah
so i think there's the basic integrity
of the system i do not question it's
possible you're right and i'm wrong and
i'm naive but i'm just saying where i'm
coming from on this
the broader question about how we
conduct elections in america is
it's ridiculous how we conduct elections
in america
i mean we have no national standards
essentially
we have this unbelievable patchwork of
jurisdictions those password of
jurisdictions means that everything from
the ballot design to the processes for
counting are completely different from
county to county from district district
different places right there's this
total local control
those differences tend to reinforce as
opposed to mitigate disparities in
wealth and racial disparities
and we could do a whole lot better and
in fact there was a push there was
actually a bill signed after the
disaster that was 2000
um that was a bit of reform on this on
this in this
respect that basically petered out and
has never really been particularly well
implemented and was pretty soft to begin
with so i think there's a whole bunch of
ways that we run elections in this
country that could be a lot better than
they are
but
i am yet at the point where i have
a distrust or a presumptive distrust of
the integrity of the actual results
all right
well thanks guys
every weekend book tv offers 40